>> WE ARE INSPIRED WITH WHAT’S
GOING AROUND THE COUNTRY.
PEOPLE REACHING OUT TO EACH
OTHER, HELPING OUT, LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
FOLLOWING THE DIRECTIONS OF THE
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS, THIS
IS A PROUD MOMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
AND FOR THE COUNTRY.
AND WE ARE GOING TO WIN THIS
BATTLE IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE.
>> Martha: SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER IN MITCH McCONNELL ON
THE PASSAGE OF A $2 TRILLION
RELIEF PACKAGE.
STATE, LOCAL BUSINESSES GETTING
PART OF THE DEAL, LARGE, LOANS
WILL HELP THEM.
3 MILLION AMERICANS LOST THEIR
JOBS IN THE WAKE OF COVID-19
ALREADY.
THIS PACKAGE IS THE LARGEST
ECONOMIC RESCUE IN THE HISTORY
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HERE ARE NOW EXCLUSIVELY BY
PHONE TONIGHT, LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL.
LEADER McCONNELL, THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TONIGHT.
I KNOW YOU SAID THIS IS A GOOD
MOMENT.
THE VOTE GOT 96% SENATE SUPPORT,
CORRECT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, MARTHA,
WE PIVOTED FROM IMPEACHMENT, ONE
OF THE MOST CONTENTIOUS.
YOU CAN IMAGINE, AND PASSING
THIS 96-0 IN THE SENATE.
CAME TOGETHER IN LESS THAN A
WEEK WHICH IS A VERY CHALLENGING
THING TO DO IN CONGRESS.
LOTS OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PEOPLE AND DIFFERENT POINTS OF
VIEW.
AND WE DELIVERED IT.
I’M CONFIDENT THAT HOUSE WILL
PASS IT TOMORROW.
>> Martha: IN TERMS OF THE
HOUSE, NANCY PELOSI SAID THANKS
GOODNESS WE GOT OUR ARMS AROUND
THIS THING.
REPUBLICANS WANTED IT TO BE JUST
A BIG GIFT TO CORPORATIONS IN
AMERICA, AND WE WRESTLED WITH IT
AND MADE IT SOMETHING THAT WORKS
FOR THE AMERICAN WORKER AND THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> I WISH NANCY WOULD TURN OFF
ALL THOSE POLITICAL TALKING
POINTS.
AN AWFUL LOT OF AMERICANS WORK
FOR BIG COMPANIES, SO WE DIDN’T
WANT TO EXCLUDE THE EMPLOYEES
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE SIZE OF
THEIR EMPLOYER.
SHE KNOWS BETTER THAN THAT.
THAT’S JUST THE KIND OF THING
THAT SHE ROUTINELY SAYS.
I HOPE IT COMFORTS OR MEMBERS
BECAUSE I WANT THEM TO TAKE UP
AND PASS THIS BILL THAT NOT A
SINGLE REPUBLICAN IN THE SENATE
OPPOSED.
>> Martha: ALREADY TALKED WHAT
COMES NEXT, THIS IS JUST AN
EMERGENCY RELIEF BILL AT
2 TRILLION.
AS I SAID, THE LARGEST PACKAGE
EVER TO RESCUE THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
HERE IS NANCY PELOSI, ONE MORE
THOUGHT FROM HER ABOUT WHAT
COMES NEXT.
>> WE HAD A PROPOSAL IN THE
LEGISLATION THAT MY
UNDERSTANDING WAS, I TRUSTED
IT’S TRUE, THE PRESIDENT
SUPPORTED, BUT
SENATOR McCONNELL WOULDN’T DO
IT, BUT SAID WE’LL DO IT IN THE
NEXT BILL.
WE ARE READY FOR THAT.
>> SO WHAT IS THE NEXT BILL AND
HOW MANY MORE PHASES OF THIS DO
YOU SEE, SIR?
>> WE HAVE A PENSION PROBLEM BUT
IT’S NOT RELATED TO THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THAT’S WHY IT’S NOT IN THE BILL.
>> Martha: IT’S NOT.
>> THE EMERGENCY BILL THAT WE
MAY HAVE TO PASS NEEDS TO BE
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT AND SOME
ELBOWING CAME ON WITH THE
SPEAKER CAME BACK FROM
CALIFORNIA AND TRY TO GET BACK
ON THE TALKS IN THE SENATE BILL
ABOUT SUGGESTING A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT WERE COMPLETELY
UNRELATED TO THE CORONA VIRUS
CRISIS BUT WERE RELATED TO
DEMOCRAT POLICY AGENDAS.
WE AREN’T GOING TO USE THE VIRUS
REALLY BILLS AS A WAY TO PAST
DEMOCRATIC PROPOSALS.
THAT’S NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
>> Martha: I’M ABOUT TO TALK
TO ECONOMIST EVEN MORE WHO
SOMETIMES ADVISES THE
WHITE HOUSE ON ISSUES OF THE
ECONOMY.
HE SAYS HE’S VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE 100% PAY IN THE BILL
FOR FOUR MONTHS.
HE SAID HE WANTS TO GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK AND HE SAID THAT’S
NOT GOING TO PROVIDE AN
INCENTIVE, IN SOME CASES PEOPLE
WOULD GET MORE THAN 100% OF
THEIR NORMAL PAYCHECK IN THIS
PLAN.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> WE ARE ALL WRESTLING TO THAT.
WE HAD TO LISTEN TO DR. FAUCI,
DR. BIRX.
WE CAN’T GET BACK TO NORMAL
TOTALLY UNTIL WE DEFEAT THIS
VIRUS.
OUR HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
WHO DON’T HAVE A POLITICAL LABEL
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO CAN HELP US
GET OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC WHICH
IS CREATING THE ECONOMIC
PROBLEM.
IT IS A TOUGH CALL.
WE ALL WANT TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL.
MOST AMERICANS ARE NOT GOING TO
COME DOWN WITH THIS VIRUS.
THEY ARE ALL SUFFERING FROM
CABIN FEVER HOWEVER BECAUSE THEY
ARE STUCK AT HOME MANY OF THEM.
UNABLE TO GET OUT, UNABLE TO GET
THIS ECONOMY, WHICH IS ROARING,
BUT BACK UP AGAIN.
>> Martha: ARE YOU JUST
CONCERNED THAT WE HAVE OVERBLOWN
THIS IN ANY WAY?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CLAW BACK
ON SOME OF THE ASSESSMENTS IN
THESE MODELS AND THE U.K., THE
EPIDEMIOLOGIST ADVISING THE
PRIME MINISTER THERE DECIMATING
HIS OWN ESTIMATES OF WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN HERE, WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT?
>> I THINK WE NEED TO FOLLOW THE
ADVICE OF THE BEST PROFESSIONALS
WE HAVE IN AMERICA AND I HAVE
TOTAL CONFIDENCE IN DR. BIRX AND
DR.  FAUCI, THEY ARE THE BEST WE
HAVE IN THE FACE OF HIS PANDEMIC
AND I THINK WE NEED TO FOLLOW
THEIR ADVICE.
>> Martha: WE’LL SEE THE OTHER
PHASES OF THIS THAT ARE COMING.
ARE WE GOING TO SEE $3 TRILLION,
$4 TRILLION IN RELIEF HERE OVER
THE COURSE OF THESE OTHER PHASES
BEFORE I LET YOU GO, SENATOR?
>> WE HAVE TO LOOK WAIT AND SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
I’VE SENT THE SENATE HOME UNTIL
APRIL 20TH.
WE CAN CALL EVERYONE BACK IF
THERE IS A NEED TO ACT AGAIN.
BUT YOU KNOW, THE VIRUS INVADED
THE SENATE.
AT THE END, WE WE HAD THREE MEMB
OUT WHO WERE IN QUARANTINE AS WE
VOTED LAST NIGHT.
IT WAS TIME HAVING FINISHED THE
JOB FOR US TO FOLLOW THE
INSURANCE INSTRUCTIONS COMMITTAL
THE HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
HAVE BEEN GIVING ALL OF THEIR
AMERICANS.
>> Martha:
SENATOR McCONNELL, THANK YOU